[Music]
money that which separates the haves
from the have-nots patience frugality
sacrifice deciding to invest in your
family's future and taking
responsibility for the consequences of
those actions Trevor Evans FBI we're
going on we believe your husband's
partner was murdered one let's all stop
playing this game shall we
lying running both tired we made a
choice to move our family to a more
peaceful place mom what are we doing
here
your father's laundering money for a
Mexican drug cartels okay where's my
fight with all of us someone's going to
die
relax I don't wanna have this feeling we
both know that you'd be better off dead
we're gonna kill your family have you
done with all this tremendous she's it
smart if he knows the kid's name
last chance for witness protection this
is just another betrayal isn't it how
long you been planning this
you have walled me
the money is at its essence that measure
of a man's choices
with you do today for our family
[Music]